today we're going to be speaking with
david feidler who's a writer philosopher
and also author of the recently
published book breakfast with seneca a
stoic guide to the art of living which
is a clear and accurate guide to the
teachings of the stoic philosopher
seneca david it's really great having
you on i appreciate it hey it's uh great
to speak with you david so
particularly during the pandemic on
social media and elsewhere
stoicism as a philosophy has has become
very very much in vogue with a lot of
different people
posting everything from memes to
articles about it and often there's this
kind of very
top level understanding that
stoicism means showing little emotion
and just sort of being only
slightly connected to the world around
you which is not at all what the
philosophy advocates for so so maybe we
could start there with what what is the
the what is stoicism
right that's a really uh good starting
point and uh stoicism it's an ancient uh
greek and roman philosophy of life
but uh
the issue that you're alluding to is uh
the word stoic has actually changed to
mean something totally else over the
course of like many centuries the
philosophy itself is like
2300 years old
and now
stoicism means to repress your emotions
or keep a stiff upper lip and
that has nothing to do with the original
philosophy in fact
the stoics
were
uh not unemotional in any way they
experienced regular emotions and they
thought they were fine the only problem
that the stoics had was with extreme
negative emotions which they felt arose
from incorrect opinions and they saw
those extreme negative emotions as being
things like anger
worry
anxiety
and things like that
so how did someone like seneca
what framework did seneca advocate for
for dealing with those negative emotions
okay
um
one of the most central teachings of
stoicism this is something that all of
the roman stoics uh believed in
and this is probably a huge takeaway for
the people who are listening to this
discussion today is that
their idea was that we can't control
what actually happens to us but we can
control how we respond to things they
all believed in that
and um the main idea was that uh it's
not really things or events that upset
us but the opinions or judgments that we
hold about things and an example of this
that i use in the book is uh imagine
it's like raining and you're walking
along one day uh and you walk by a big
puddle and a car comes by and splashes
you and you're covered with water well
someone might have the mental opinion
that well i just got splashed which is a
pretty objective way of looking at
things but another person might think oh
you've ruined my entire day and then
develop a sense of anger and rage about
that and then want to uh get even with
the driver in some way so that shows how
the opinions that we hold about things
really uh influence our emotional states
or even act as the seed of these extreme
negative emotions and
uh this belief uh it's not things or
events that upset us but the opinions we
hold about things that's the origin of
what is now known as cognitive therapy
or cognitive behavioral therapy and the
stoics really uh
invented cognitive therapy that's what
uh their theory of emotion was about and
the modern people the modern
psychologists who invented cognitive
therapy actually drew on these stoic
ideas and mentioned the stoics by name
yeah you know as i hear you talk about
it there's this book from the 20th
century by viktor frankl man's search
for meaning which i don't think is
overtly about stoicism but he lays out
in the context of surviving the
holocaust
a very similar idea about he could not
control his circumstances but he could
control
the reaction he had to those
circumstances which seems quite similar
exactly and uh
i think there's a very famous saying
attributed to him that
our freedom exists in the fact that
we're able to pause
before
we make a decision or a judgment and
that's really our source of freedom now
uh apparently he didn't say that he went
back to rallo may but the the thought is
the same and certainly his his idea uh
you know is an exact parallel to that of
the stoics
one of the kind of big
pushbacks and reactions i see to this
recent popularization of stoicism
are comments along the lines of yeah
that's really great to think about if
your basic needs are met and you have
time to hang out on social media or
reading books but if you're not sure
where your next meal is coming from or
you don't have housing or you need
health care and can't afford it stoicism
is not useful in that way and it's
another one of these sort of now
becoming commercialized ideas that
spread on social media
how would you react to that critique of
the popularization of stoicism um
well um
i don't think that's really true because
uh now seneca actually was very wealthy
uh the the person the stoic philosopher
i wrote the book about he was actually
one of the wealthiest people in the
roman empire but the earlier greek
stoics weren't wealthy at all and
the most famous stoic to follow him
uh in rome was epictetus so epictetus
was maybe like about 15 when seneca died
and he was actually a slave
so it was a philosophy that was embraced
from slaves to roman emperors
and
certainly
all of
these stoic ideas are applicable
you know by anyone today it doesn't
matter on your level of wealth in fact
the stoics believed that our true goods
lie within us and they believe that you
know it's very valuable and it's an
advantage to have like wealth
a beautiful family a beautiful house
but it's only our inner character that
allows us to
use those things in a good way
so for the stoics the most important
part of life was really developing a
good character and that's something they
would say holds true for everyone
with um if i recall correctly seneca had
some
uh
views on crowds and and mob
mentality that
seem like they might be relevant today
to some degree including to to media and
sort of some of the other modern
things that humans today are presented
with can you talk a little bit about
that
uh sure uh actually uh seneca has the
story about how he went to see the
gladiatorial games and then
uh people were being killed in front of
his eyes and the crowd was uh cheering
for the death
of the gladiators
and
the other people that were thrown into
the ring and he was actually as far as i
can tell the first person to write about
what is now called a crowd or mob
psychology which was
a study that developed in like the mid
1800s
and
people now study things like emotional
contagions
uh
things like that and also how we
unconsciously
assimilate
the behavior of people that we're
exposed to
and this this holds very true in today's
uh sort of like internet uh world or
twitter world where uh you know you
get these uh emotional contagions that
seem to
that seem to float through the internet
and uh they're very contagious because
sometimes you'll see like a video clip
and you don't have the full context of
it and people are making judgments about
it and denouncing it and things like
that and it's very easy to get swept up
uh
in that kind of behavior and seneca
warned about that specifically if he was
alive today he would say you know take a
step back
and uh
don't ascend
you know immediately to the the judgment
of the crowd or the mob but wait until
things become clarified and also
you know be mindful of due process as
well uh you can't make those judgments
just based on a tweet
oftentimes usually you need further
information
um
what was uh you you write in the book
about
the
value of time
and of not postponing what one wants to
do sort of indefinitely or i mean
maybe even to any degree beyond what
what's kind of logistically necessary
can you talk a little bit about that in
the connection to stoicism
right
well uh this is something that's really
specific to seneca he writes about this
a lot and he says that time is our most
valuable asset so
um people are very careful about the way
that they guard their wealth but when it
comes to guarding their time they don't
even think about it
usually and
his idea is that people spend a lot of
time rushing around and acting as though
they're preoccupied with things whereas
it's it's more of an act sometimes and
he felt that
we should be very careful about the way
that we
use our time uh what i would say
he actually talks about for example like
how people
believe that
they'll someday retire
and they spend their entire life working
but then he says how do you know that
you'll live to be 50 or 60 years old you
could die at any moment
and his his idea was like finding some
kind of balance between work and leisure
and he would have agreed with the modern
idea that uh
uh we should work to live rather than
live to work
yeah that you know sometimes
you you you get these um
distortions i guess i would say
of some of these precepts and they are
sort of exaggerated and taken to the
extreme where like what you just said
would be taken to mean you know this
kind of you only live once
don't plan for the future at all kind of
mentality but really the it seems to me
the value in thinking about these things
is about finding some kind of balance
that that makes sense rather than
picking some extreme to adhere to
exactly and that's something that
everyone really has to deal with on
their own because everyone's life is
different so how
one person will find the kind of balance
between life and work will be different
than another person but it's certainly a
an important question to think about
going back a little bit to the social
contagion thing which you know we i you
explained and i think is really clear
when it comes to like stuff on the
internet as an example when you look at
the socio political system maybe
specifically in in the united states
what are some other areas in which this
social contagion is taking place that
would be interesting to be aware of
well i think actually
one of the reasons that this has become
such a phenomenon is it's exacerbated by
the internet
and another aspect of it also is that
the the internet has been very good for
many things for example we can have
discussions like this but in other ways
i think it's been very very negative
because people base journalistic
coverage now on the number of clicks
that stories get so uh journalism has
become very click-baity and it's also uh
really harmed you know serious print
journalism so uh basically
journalists and the media have every
every reason to encourage
people getting angry about things for
example because you know it's those
stories that make people angry that uh
usually have the highest
you know click-through rates
yeah and i mean we see that daily where
a story that we spend
a while researching about
to take today you know the build-up to
what's going on with russia and ukraine
right it just is not going to generate
even a fraction of the interest that
joe biden calling that fox reporter a
son of a [ __ ] yesterday is going to
generate and if you ask me which is most
substantively valuable it's obviously
the geopolitical impact with historical
uh implications of the ukraine russia
thing but it's not it
for all the reasons you're talking about
it's just not going to do as well right
um you know another thing too is that
you have these huge media platforms now
and so they have a certain amount of
space allotted for you know the
so-called news so that if nothing's
happening they actually have to fill it
with something yes
yeah no that that's that's certainly an
issue as well um when it comes to uh
marcus aurelius is often sort of your
book focuses on seneca but you mentioned
seneca epictetus marcus aurelius kind of
the third in the maybe most three known
uh stoics
what does his perspective did his
perspective differ in significant ways
from that of seneca
um
it's really interesting because when i
was researching the book i looked into
this in a great deal of depth
and it's surprising
how uh similar the views of the three
main roman stoics were for example an
average reader wouldn't notice this but
all three of the roman stoics believed
that when you were on your deathbed
that you should feel a sense of
gratitude when you're dying for the gift
of life that the universe has given to
you
and i find that to be amazing and that
for them would be a mark of a life that
was well well lived and that was the
whole point of philosophy is to
live a life that's truly worth living so
if you
felt a deep sense of regret on your
deathbed that would probably mean that
you felt that you had made some very
serious errors in your life um another
idea that i think is very important for
people today um that comes from the
stoics all of the stoics believed in
this they were the most pro-social
philosophers in the ancient world and
they taught that we should all
contribute to society marcus aurelius
was obsessed with this his meditations
is a a pretty short book but he he
reminds himself like it was his personal
notebook he reminds himself 80 times
to contribute to the common good
and
and the stoics uh they didn't believe
these things in the way that a religious
person would believe them because they
were philosophers so they always had an
argument for this and their argument was
that all people are born with the
faculty of reason which makes us
rational creatures
and it also makes us equal to one
another so the stoics were the first
philosophical school to say that human
beings were equal to one another the
idea of human equality and it also means
that because we have this spark of
reason in common uh there's a you know
universal brotherhood or sisterhood of
humanity that we're all part of
and
that means we should help each other and
over the course of centuries it took a
very long time this stoic idea led to
the idea of human rights equality and
ultimately to the elimination of slavery
in some ways because the enlightenment
philosophers who were talking about
human rights
and criticizing the institution of
slavery were very familiar with these
stoic views and and drew upon them
incredible uh historical context and
some of what we've been talking about
today is in the book breakfast with
seneca a stoic guide to the art of
living we've been speaking with the
book's author writer and philosopher
david feidler really appreciate your
time today and your insights
great it's been wonderful speaking with
you